on Wednesday Parliament remembered the
victims of the chernobyl nuclear
disaster on april the 26 30 years ago in
ukraine hi many were killed remains
undetermined but millions were affected
hundreds of thousands evacuated from
their homes people dirty teacher but I
politician not so large that Asian
strides in vague missin voz need for
that of ironing industrial saga of its
acog Nam the septum cavaquinho oppa
needles on BBM she hasn't at mini
plenary on Thursday the implementation
of the eu-turkey deal on migration was
debated some highlighted its advances
others voice concern about fundamental
rights violations in Turkey non puoi
search in assume barato salter a mo de
respeto deidre to money suntory no de
respeto del parral is model informazioni
sul treno de respeto delhi mean Iran say
Tuesday so a big conference with Muslim
community members to discuss how to stop
Islamic radicalization the recent
Brussels attacks were the latest show of
terror by the so-called Islamic state
one conclusion of the conference
dialogue is the key to stopping radical
jihadism laying rot to the religion of
Islam quality monster allegation Islam
case in peenya controller degradation
well yeah okay leave Islam easily
terrorist his parent no me digas paragon
trow deal measures to improve into a you
railway operations and boost the role of
the european railway agency were debated
and voted on by any Peas on thursday
they should prepare national networks
for liberalisation there are more than
two hundred and fifteen thousand
kilometres of track and more than 800
companies active in the sector in the EU
of as vicious is there technician phyla
does England via the old-fashioned barn
again to it does d but in ANOVA tunis
lets the water
fearless into battle defending the
defenseless against imagined enemies don
quijote and his faithful servant Sancho
lay siege to the European Parliament the
ultimate figure of noble self-delusion
was here to promote culture as the
essential foundation for European
citizenship and the Father Almighty on
Oliver lavertus los grandes creadores
son lalu Kula para Europa lagu hula
tambien para los políticos europea